today on the Matt Walsh show mayors and
governors across the country are getting
very tough on quote-unquote criminals
who violate social distancing directives
but why aren't they ever this tough on
real crime and five headlines including
president Trump's claim that over two
million people would have died without a
lockdown we will analyze that is there
any truth to that whatsoever there isn't
by the way but not to give a spoiler but
we'll talk about that and Alex Jones
announces his plan to eat his neighbor's
and in our daily cancellation I must
cancel my own child my own flesh and
blood I hate to do it it's not something
any father ever wants to do but I have
no choice and I will explain why all of
that coming up but first this is very
important as well given the week that
we're in I want to tell you something
about our friends over at books you know
Mother's Day is on the way my wife
reminded me that of that yesterday she
said by the way Mother's Day is this
coming weekend just so you know FYI
you know hint hint nudge nudge father
mother's day is is is on the way and
just because you can't be with your mom
on Mother's Day that doesn't mean that
you can't do something for her in fact
it certainly doesn't get you off the
hook you still have to do something for
so you can't give mom a hug but you can
send flowers from the books company
books you know that short for bouquets
books are responsibly sourced from some
of the world's finest eco-friendly farms
even farms on the sides of volcanoes so
you get volcano flowers out of the deal
flowers stay fresher longer did you know
that flowers and plants have been proven
to reduce stress and boost productivity
I didn't know that now you do now that
we're spending more time at home how
about a little self-love to brighten
your day
and your space so you know you could buy
these flowers for your mom for your wife
you also buy them for yourself and this
means that you know you know it wouldn't
if you're if you're if if you're not
doing something for your mom and
Mother's Day if not some doing something
good for your mom's mom and Mother's Day
that just makes you a bad person I think
so don't be a bad person send smiles in
the matter of the miles with bucks comm
slash Walsh that's Bo you cue s.com
slash Walsh and enter code walls for 25%
off your entire order again that's code
walls for 25% off at bucks comm slash
Walsh also another holiday today it's
May 4th of course so has a huge Star
Trek fan I just want to say you know
happy May 4th may the 4th be with you as
they say you know call me a nerd but I
feel like we're all Gryffindor's today
to quote Frodo Baggins anyway someone to
mention that now first thing off the top
here because it's starting to annoy me
maybe it shouldn't because it doesn't
affect me but when has that ever gotten
in the way of something annoying me I
just want to say you know you don't need
to wear a mask when you're driving in
your car I don't if you knew that or
when you're walking down the street or
going for a jog unless there's a
ordinance in your town requiring that
although even in that case I would say
probably you should you still shouldn't
wear it in those circumstances because
it's insane
now where I live there definitely is no
ordinance requiring you to wear a mask
anywhere but but at the store
yet in the last few days I've seen
people wearing masks in the car wearing
them while they walk down the street I
saw a guy out in his garden working in
his yard with a mask on I saw somebody
jogging with a mask on and I assure you
if you are one of those people let let
me just lay any concerns that you might
have this is not necessary the virus is
not going to leap in your car window and
attack you it's it is not spread that
way if somebody coughs on the sidewalk
while you're driving down the road the
chance of you being infected is
effectively zero I mean I guess it's not
literally zero but then again the chance
of you being abducted by space aliens or
physically assaulted by Bigfoot also is
not literally zero so it's effectively
for all intents and purposes it's it's a
zero percent chance and if you're
walking down the street outside even if
you pass by another person we have no
data to suggest that transmission is
happening under those conditions I'm not
aware of a single confirmed case
anywhere in the world where two people
walking each past each other outside
managed to pass it to each other so you
can you know just
take it easy with that I'm not saying
don't wear a mask I'm just saying that
wearing a mask everywhere all the time
is unnecessary and it's kind of crazy
and I'm seeing it a lot and I think it
contributes to the panic and the fear
you know it gives people the wrong
impression and you're helping to keep
the lockdowns going longer by
contributing to the public perception
that this virus is some sort of magical
super bug that can infect you no matter
where you are or what you're doing or
how close you are to another person you
know I read these polls in fact I just
read one before going on the air this is
from The Guardian actually it's a poll
from the UK but it's similar a similar
situation is here the headline is
fearful Britons remain strongly opposed
to lifting coronavirus lockdown and I
read stuff like that and polls here in
the US like I said are are saying
similar things and that most people
supposedly want the lockdown to continue
they don't want to leave their homes
they don't want to get to any back to
any sort of semblance of their normal
lives I read that my first reaction is
to think no way there's just no way that
after two months of this and the
destruction of our economy the erasure
of our liberties there's no way that
people are in the mood for more of it I
can't possibly imagine that especially
in this country in America I mean we're
Americans we we like to be free we like
to do what we want to do that's my first
bag and I still think the polls are
exaggerated or skewed by the way the
question is framed like if the person
conducting the poll is is giving the you
know the the poll taker two options and
one is do you want the lockdown to
continue or do you want to do nothing
whatsoever to mitigate the virus then a
lot of people are going to choose the
former rather than the latter but of
course that erases the middle option
where there's no lockdown but we're
still doing things to mitigate the virus
so you know you take all that into
account
i it does seem though that even taking
that into consideration it seems that a
large preponderance of people
maybe a majority I don't know are still
nearly incapacitated by fear and would
still rather hide under their beds
indefinitely then go back out and start
living their lives and that's why I'm
saying if we're ever going to have our
lives back and our country back and our
economy back and our Liberty back and
our dignity back I think it's incumbent
on all of us to project a sense of calm
and a sense of confidence I'm not saying
that we should in socially distance or
that we shouldn't ever wear a mask or we
shouldn't take basic precautions I'm not
saying any of those things but I am
saying that we should not be overly
fearful and panicked and unreasonably
scared or just unreasonable in general
the sorts of people who now refuse to
walk to the mailbox without a surgical
mask on that's that's that's not what we
should be doing or in fact I did see
someone walk into their mailbox box with
a scarf wrapped around their face I
guess it's possible that they were just
cold but then you know it's like sixty
degrees here so I doubt it like a scarf
rack wrapped under things like they're
like they're charging into a burning
building or something just walk into the
mailbox and there's no reason for that
so let's all let's all just calm down a
little bit and and try to be reasonable
now I also wanted to talk about this to
start the show Mayor Lori Lightfoot in
Chicago has been speaking of being
unreasonable
she's been certainly unreasonable and
one of the most and and her a lack of
reason also certainly does affect other
people in a very direct way she's been
one of the most tyrannical dictators
through this entire thing
she has just really enjoyed being
playing the part of Empress of Chicago
and you could tell she's getting a big
kick out of it and on that note here she
is over the weekend doing more of her
tough guy or tough girl routine now I've
directed Superintendent Brown to order
all Police District to give special
attention to these parties and this is
how it's gonna be we will shut you down
we will cite you and if we need to we
will arrest you and we will take you to
jail period there should be nothing
unambiguous about that don't make us
treat you like a criminal but if you act
like a criminal and you violate the law
and you refuse to do what is necessary
to save lives in the city in the middle
of a pandemic we will take you to jail
period so there you go not to be
pedantic but but but firstly there
should be nothing unambiguous about that
means that there should be something
ambiguous about it so what you were
saying there is that she wants it to be
ambiguous because otherwise now I think
what you meant to say is that there
should that that this should be
unambiguous or there should be nothing
ambiguous about it but anyway if you're
if you're going for the tough guy
routine you have to really nail the
lines otherwise it doesn't work
but there's a lot more to say in
reaction to that and we will do that but
first a word from legacy box you know as
we were talking about Mother's Day on
the way and a lot of great gifts you can
get from Mother's Day one thing that
your mom is always excited to receive is
pictures of you even though she knows
what you look like that's the crazy
thing but more pictures of you she's
really gonna be into that and that's
what legacy box is great with legacy box
is a super simple mail and service to
have all of your home movies and
pictures digitally preserved on a thumb
drive DVD or the cloud don't let those
priceless family memories disappear
because that's what happens you know
they just they just dissipate into the
ether instead here's an idea
mother's days fast approaching and he
had a so think about what are you
getting for Mom how about memories that
will never get dusty or fade away legacy
box helps bring new life to your old
media by unlocking those trapped family
memories and putting them in a modern
digital format that's easy to use
you know I've used this myself and the
first thing that comes to mind with
legacy boxes just how just how easy it
is to use
first of all and then it puts all this
stuff because I'm a very disorganized
person I can say we've got boxes of old
DVDs and pictures and stuff laying
around so this puts it all in one place
I'm not going to lose it that's what I
love about it legacy box is a way for
you to easily and affordably digitally
preserve your past the process from
start to finish is like I said so easy
you pack and send your tapes they're
there too legacy box their team
digitizes everything by hand and you get
back perfectly preserved digital copies
on a thumb drive DVD or the cloud it's
that easy so for a limited time
legacy box is running a 50% off Mother's
Day special order your legacy box today
to take advantage of this incredible
offer this is one of the best discounts
they've ever offered legacy box is
perfect for you or for someone you love
go to legacy box comm slash Walsh and
say 50% off while supplies last
okay so mayor lawyer Lori Lightfoot says
that if you violate social distancing
then your criminal a crook a fugitive
from justice which means of course that
she is - she is all those things a
criminal crook a fugitive a danger to
commit to her community after all
remember this is the woman who got her
hair cut a couple weeks ago even after
forcibly shutting down all of the hair
salons and barbershops and everything in
the city and legally prohibiting anyone
else from getting a haircut she went out
and got a haircut
and just just for fun - uh speaking of
remembering things to reminisce let's go
back and recall the excuse she gave
after she was caught getting her hair
cut here was her excuse I'm the public
face of this city I'm on national media
and I'm out in the public eye and you
know I'm a I'm a person who I take my
personal hygiene very seriously as I
said I felt like I needed to have a
haircut I'm not able to do that myself
and so I got a haircut so she's in the
she's in the public eye and she takes
hygiene seriously unlike the average
filthy Chicago Reza doesn't care about
hygiene
apparently so I take hygiene seriously I
don't know about the rest of these other
rubes they don't so they don't they
don't need to
darica they don't need to take showers
their peasants you know their dirty
peasants but I I am the mayor and I need
to practice good hygiene because and you
also know the other thing about mayor
Lightfoot is she of course is renowned
for her looks so she needs of course to
get that haircut and as the face of the
city and everything but in any case
she's a she's a criminal by her own
character categorization she is a
criminal the other point we've seen
course similar rhetoric like this from
Emperor de Blasio we know about him
threatening to round up the Jews
threatening to close churches
permanently if they defy his wishes
Empress whitmer barring people from even
buying seeds and that sort of thing many
other mayors and governors across the
country we've heard this and we've
talked about how this is a power trip
from them so a lot of this rhetoric is
just them enjoying being absolute
supreme ruler they're getting a kick out
of it I think there's another aspect of
this that's important to understand so
ask yourself before this before the
corona virus when did you ever see
Lightfoot or Whitmer or de Blasio
especially or any of the rest of them
getting up in front of cameras and
taking this kind of hard stance against
actual criminals I mean Chicago has lost
a hell of a lot of people over the years
over recent years to gang violence
drug-related violence etc in the long
term that is still going to be a greater
threat to residents of Chicago than
corna virus will prove to be and this is
the case for every American city they've
all got crime and and and everything
else yet these mayor's aren't nearly as
tough on actual crime actual deadly
crime as they are on people who walk too
closely to each other on the sidewalk so
I think a big part of the motivation
here is that it gives these weak mayors
and governors an excuse to act like
they're tough on crime act like they
care about protecting their citizens
they're too afraid to take this kind of
stance under normal circumstances
because they're afraid of charges of
cruelty or brutality or racism or
whatever else but here they can do it
and they can get away with it in fact I
think there's a lot of this kind of
posturing going around so here's another
example I saw this tweet yesterday and
I've seen and I'm just using this as an
example cuz I've seen this kind of
suggestion it's it's not entirely
serious so half-serious suggesting but
I've seen this bandied about quite a bit
so let me show you this here's the tweet
it's got a thousand likes and says
friend in Bay Area law enforcement had a
funny idea no tickets no arrests for
social distance violations just put a
mark on their driver's license that
means do not treat fork ovid if they
show up at a hospital little harsh but
it does put ashtag skin in the game like
I said I've heard this from a lot of
people like if you if you violate social
distance again you get sick from
coronavirus you don't deserve medical
treatment or whatever but this again is
the kind of hardline stance
you never hear during normal times after
all if we aren't treating people for
coronavirus because they violate social
distancing what about refusing treatment
for people who sleep around when they
get STDs or refusing to treat someone
with heart disease if they eat fast food
while refusing the treat an alcoholic
for liver damage or a smoker for lung
cancer not only would that never be
suggested but the same people who will
scream at you for going to the park or
to the beach during the carnival hours
will also scream at you if you dare
suggest that obese people who eat fast
food are being self-destructive so it's
a lot of posturing going on and by the
way I'm not suggesting that an obese
person with heart disease shouldn't be
treated because they ate fast food
that's not my approach but I also
wouldn't suggest that about coronavirus
now if you if you go to the park or if
you go to the beach and then you get
coronavirus first of all if somebody
goes to the beach and then a week later
they're in the hospital for coronavirus
the chance that they got it at the beach
is very very very small there are many
others it's more likely that they got it
at Walmart or the grocery store when
they were grocery shopping but either
way no matter where they got it they
still deserve to be treated let's go on
to headlines number one Donald Trump was
on Fox News last night here he is making
an interesting claim when you look at
the other side that that you're on the
other side medically or do you think
that as deaths are going up and cases
are going up that we really are on the
other side medically and that this is a
great success story from the federal
government well I can own well it's too
soon to say that really I guess because
you know we're still in the middle of
something but certainly we would have
lost a lot more people Brett if we would
have done as an example you call it
heard if we would have done heard in
other words everything's wonderful let's
just keep going along per a minute we
were the last two and a half million
people I think or a million and a half
or two million people no I think we've
done I think the American people have
done a good job this is a tragic
situation everybody knows somebody
that's been affected that's a very rare
thing okay now this is nonsense from
chompin whether you however you feel
about Trump you're a big Trump supporter
this is still nonsense total nonsense
and we shouldn't accept this kind of
fear MA even if you're a trump supporter
I don't think you should accept this
kind of fear-mongering nonsense from
Trump any more than you accept it from
anybody else in fact you should accept
it less from the guy you support two and
a half million without a lockdown that's
crazy
where is he getting that number well
he's getting that number I think he's
partially getting it from his own
imagination he's also partially getting
it from models that have been abandoned
for weeks now these models were
abandoned weeks ago if an on lockdown
strategy would kill two and a half
million people then Sweden which has not
employed a lockdown strategy should have
way more deaths right now than it
currently does and besides for the
umpteenth time the choice was not
between locking down or doing nothing
Trump says if we had said everything is
fine nobody ever said that we should say
everything is fine I mean arguably Trump
himself was sort of saying that are
nearly saying that back in
March when he said the virus had
infected 15 people and it would go away
after that he did say that but most
people that's that's not the point we've
been making the other option is not
doing nothing or acting like everything
is fine the other option is to protect
vulnerable compute communities practice
social distancing where needed and
possible and yes develop herd immunity
which which is going to have to happen
anyway there is no getting around it it
will have to happen you cannot avoid it
so the other strategy is avoid economic
collapse protect the vulnerable and get
on with doing the thing that we have to
do anyway and that right now we're just
delaying that that's the idea two and a
half million dead from that come on in
this think about this ok in this country
20,000 of our deaths so far that we know
of are in nursing homes in some European
countries according to the studies that
have been done half of their deaths are
in nursing homes what does that mean it
means we could have significantly
decreased the death rate just by
shutting down nursing homes earlier and
using our resources to protect
vulnerable populations when you add up I
mean want to think about this and I
don't have the numbers right in front of
me but you can you can go and google it
so add up the number of people killed in
nursing homes
the number of general 75-plus deaths
that are not in nursing homes I don't
know if you could find that specific
number and then also throw in the death
rate in New York City and much of that
is in nursing homes but the non nursing
home deaths in New York City okay you
take all that into account and that is a
huge preponderance of the overall deaths
in America which me what does that mean
does it mean that that doesn't that
doesn't matter and of course it matters
the point is we could have protected
people 75 Plus that's majority then not
working anyway so you know having them
not work is not a problem they don't
work anyway protect the nursing homes
and and then yeah if you want to do a
lockdown in New York City which has been
hit way harder than anywhere else
because for a few reasons because it's
got the subway system which has been a
vector for disease it's it got
population density of like 27,000 people
per square mile I mean there are a lot
of unique things in New York City so you
address those specific situations and
you have mitigated much of the death
just from that but once once you take
those deaths and you set them aside just
for a minute you're left with really no
justification for telling a young and
healthy guy in North Carolina or
Minnesota that Orsat or Maryland that he
can't go to work there's no
justification for it essentially you're
telling me he can't go to work because
there's a virus that's infecting New
York City people 75 plus and nursing
homes that doesn't make sense and the
other thing is if
if we had focused on that not just on
that I'm not saying we do nothing where
everyone else is concerned I mean we
still have social distancing I think in
some circumstances you should be wearing
a mask even if it wasn't required so we
do stuff like that good hygiene washing
your hands and everything else but if we
focused most of our resources on
protecting the vulnerable shutting down
nursing homes rather than expending
resources on trying to enforce a house
arrest on hundreds of millions of
Americans if we had done that we could
have saved many of those lives that we
didn't number two and now Asia after
exporting the corona virus has decided
to give the world another gift the giant
murder Hornets the Asian murder Hornet
it's called actually the the Asian giant
Hornet I guess which whichever you call
it calling it Asian is obviously racist
but I didn't come up with a name you
know this is this isn't on me reading
from CNN for the first time the Asian
giant Hornet that's that's pretty racist
from CNN then CNN they're one of the
ones telling us do not call it the
Chinese virus and now they're calling
this the Asian Hornet that's I don't
know some anti Asian bigotry going on
here for the first time Asian giant
Hornets have been spot in the United
States specifically in Washington State
scientists say beekeepers have reported
piles of dead bees with their heads
ripped off an alarming sight in a
country with a rapidly declining bee
population and more than two inches long
they're the world's largest Hornet with
a sting that can kill humans have stung
multiple times according to experts
susan kobe a bee breeder at the
washington state says they're like
something out of a monster cartoon and
with this huge yellow orange face okay
just can I just say Asha relax okay
we're good we don't need any more deadly
plagues for now so you've supplied us
with two this year it's only May so
maybe just take a break give us a break
start thinking of what you want to do in
twenty twenty-one I know you'll have a
gift for us then but for right now if
you could just lay off please
now I thought the good news for me as a
beekeeper is that I have a
beekeeping suit that will keep me safe
and now all I have to do is wear my
surgical mask and my beekeeper suit
wherever I go and I'm protected from
both plagues but then I read this and
the same article as Washington State
Agricultural officials are asking
beekeepers and residents to report any
sightings of the giant Hornets but don't
get too close it's sting can penetrate a
regular beekeeper suit perfect and state
scientists had to order special
reinforced suits okay then I gotta go
get one of those entomologist Chris
Looney says don't try to take them out
yourself if you see them I mean if you
see a giant murder Hornet and you're
inclined to try to take it out go to do
some hand in hand hand combat don't
don't try it if you get into them run
away then call us it is really important
for us to know of every sighting if
we're gonna have any hope of eradication
all right number three Lisa bloom is a
lawyer and a big meet two proponent she
was really involved in trying to get
Trump accusers to come forward and of
course she was out against Kavanagh and
everything else and now she has finally
chimed in on the Joe Biden situation
here's what she had to say she said I
believe you Tara Reid you have people
who remember you told them about this
decades ago we know he is quote handsy
you're not asking for money
you've obviously struggled mightily with
this I still have to fight Trump so I
will support Joe but I believe you and I
am sorry
so Lisa bloom the victims advocate is
saying this is what you're saying I
believe you were raped but I still
support your rapist I mean that is
that's a hell of a position to take but
the thing is that is a as despicable and
deranged and morally debased as that
position is it is far more respectable
from then than what most most leftists
and me two people are doing because at
least it's honest okay it has the
benefit of being honest what she's
saying is I believe you I think it
happened but it's more advantageous for
me politically to support your rapist so
I'm gonna support him that's what she
say
I guess I'd morally deranged but honest
and so that puts it above all the other
leftists who are just wholesale
abandoning all the me to talking points
they've been using for years now and and
attacking Tara Reid and trying to tear
down our credibility and everything else
so Lisa bloom is getting a lot of grief
for this and I understand why deservedly
so but like I said she's being honest at
least so give her some credit for that I
guess reading now from the daily wire or
and I'm sorry the Daily Mail can't
believe I would confuse those two but
daily wire the Daily Mail are not
similar at all anyway this is a Daily
Mail says hundreds of people have been
exposed for reporting people who have
floated social distancing rules and some
are now scared they could receive a
backlash the names and addresses of
approximately 900 people in Missouri
were released as part of the media
requests under the sunshine law which
allows for the release of information
submitted to a public agency st. Louis
County had urged the community to share
details of anyone not following
guidelines in response to the corona
virus pandemic and noted in the terms of
conditions that information may be
shared publicly however some people may
not have read the small print and
submitted the tips via online and now
their informations out there oh I mean I
I just feel terrible for them don't you
really really horrible sorry about your
luck there I just really terrible
tragedy
you tried to snitch on your neighbors
and thought you're being you're doing it
privately and now and now the the
Sunshine Law has snitched on you you're
being snitched on for snitching just
that's yeah no that's that's not justice
at all is it that's just a terrible
terrible thing that's all I'll say about
that five finally Alex Jones last week
had some interesting thoughts to share
listen to this I'll admit it I will eat
my neighbor's I'm not letting my kids
done I'm just gonna be honest my
superpowers being honest I've
extrapolated this out and I won't have
to for a few years I got food and stuff
but I'm literally looking at my
neighbor's now going I ready to hang
them up and got them and scan them and
chop them up you know what I'm ready my
daughters aren't starving to death I'll
eat my neighbors see my superpower is
being honest I'll eat your it I will I'm
calm
that model autumn self-sufficiency
probably the leader the point is is if
you thought about that yet because I'm
somebody that thought I could fix this
and I'm starting to think about having
to eat my neighbors you think I like
sizing up my neighbor how I'm gonna haul
him up by chain and chop his axe up I'll
do it my children aren't going hungry I
will eat your act that's why I want the
globalists to know I will eat your at
first honestly I can't judge Alex Jones
because that's exactly what I sound like
when it's been two hours since my last
snack I can't count how many times I've
said exactly this I just feel a little
bad for Alex Jones his neighbors you
know you know they were frantically on
Zillow over the weekend looking for new
living arrangements then again you know
I thought that but then I thought well
given that they live next Alex Jones
they were probably prepared for this
contingency they probably had like a go
bag packed ready to make a run for it
they knew this day was coming and it
came so that's uh that's Alex Jones for
you before we're going to eat further I
got to tell you about this it's very
important because our amazing deal that
we've been talking about for weeks now
is going away tomorrow this is your last
chance when you become a daily wire
insider plus our all-access member you
get not just one tumbler but two of them
the most highly coveted beverage vessel
in existence you get two of them but
this is the last day for the deal cake
it's going away and on top of that you
also get many other amazing benefits as
well including of course as well as the
the left chest ears tumbler you also get
an ad-free website experience you get
access to all of our live broadcasts
well the full show library you get full
three hours of been Shapiro you get
access to the mailbag you get his
exclusive election insight op-eds you
got to be a member for that and then we
do these all-access shows that are a lot
of fun in fact I'll be doing one tonight
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific
but if you remember you can also take
part in those if you're an all-access
member you can become you could take
part in those as well now the deal
as I said is going away tomorrow so
remember that's too leftist tears
Tumblr's and not just one when you
become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access member and you get 10% off
with coupon code Walsh just head on over
to Delhi wired.com slash subscribe
that's daily wire comm slash subscribe
coupon code Walsh get both tumblers now
before it's too late
and finally for our daily cancellation I
have to cancel my son my oldest son heir
to the throne I have to cancel hate
cancelling but he's left me no choice
let me explain what happened so a few
days ago I I took the kids out for a
walk in the park and we're still allowed
to do that here magnanimously our
governor has through his through his
great benevolence has allowed us to walk
outside for limited periods okay and for
only approved reasons but but we were we
were on the approved list so we were we
were out and my son and went at one
point he walked too close to a tree and
a tree branched tree branch scratched
his neck and he was bleeding a little
bit
so I sensed an opportunity and I had a
brilliant idea I told him when we get
home I didn't think this would actually
work but I said when we get home I told
him he should tell mommy that he got
attacked and bitten by a squirrel and
that's what the scratch came from and I
told him if he sells it and his sister
was there and she was also gonna help
she was gonna back up the story I said
if it really sells that he might be able
to fool mommy and that will be funny so
we get home the kids running ahead of me
and they're super excited to lie to
their mother at the best of their father
because I'm just a great parent and this
is the kind of thing I tell my kids to
do and so anyway they go up and I knew
the plan worked because before I could
even walk upstairs all I heard coming
from upstairs was what a squirrel you
might have rabies and then I walk up my
wife is freaking out and she's saying
that we need to call the doctor
immediately and and my kids actually
sold it better than I did because seeing
this reaction it worked way better than
I thought it would and I only made it
about 15 seconds before I started
laughing and that and the jig was up I
you know you know I gave up the whole
the whole thing my wife was not amused
at all
but the reason my son is canceled is
that even though it was a brilliant
performance on his part but the problem
is that he also started freaking out I
thought at first he was acting and I was
really impressed I thought we got to get
this kid I was I'm never in favor of
child actors but I thought this kid has
a gift because he started freaking out
and crying that he might have rabies and
so I thought he was acting and really
selling it but then I realized that no
he Keith because my wife said you might
have rabies he thought that he might
have rabies now and even though we made
up the story about the squirrel as he
well knew so he was scratched by a tree
branch I we came up with this story and
then he fooled himself with the story
and started crying because he thought
he'd have to go to the doctors for
rabies so then my wife was able to flip
it around on me and say look oh great
look what you've done look to our poor
child you made him cry and I tried to
explain the plan was to upset her not to
upset our child but that didn't make it
any better
in you know it's it's not my fault the
kid tried to prank his mom and instead
prank himself in the process so for
falling for his own prank and getting me
in trouble my son is cancelled like I
said not something any father wants to
do but he leaves me no choice and I by
no means accept any responsibility for
any of this even though I did tell my
kids to go lie to their mom and try to
scare her into thinking that her son was
bitten by a rabid squirrel it was good
stuff it was a I was right my daughter
though I gotta say she was very
impressive she kept a straight face the
entire time I could they're only six
years old twins and at first I was
impressed and then I was very afraid
because I thought she's six years old
and she's this good at lying we're in
trouble
down the line but anyway might as well
get some enjoyment out of it while we
can and we will leave it there on that
somewhat somber notes hope you guys have
a great day talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling our technical
producer is Austin Stephens edited by
Dany D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 as American Psycho Gavin
Newsom locked down his political
opponents beaches in one of the few
conservative counties in California your
humble correspondent broke the law to
lounge in the Sun the lockdown
authoritarians don't have any arguments
anymore to defend their draconian
policies but that isn't the point the
cruelty is the point then Joe Biden
blows it when addressing sexual assault
allegations against him but it won't
matter
feminism dies with a tweet and Hollywood
tries to rewrite the history of one of
the most important women in the history
of the conservative movement all that
and more check it out on a Michael Doyle
show
[Music]